[Applaudissements]
des cours on y va et laura larrouy clame
de leroy latron le vendeur richesse
[Rires]
alors la 3 alors alors on à douna du
mocassin italien alors là trois donc on
veut de la ballerine aller en 40 jean
nourdine ballerine au 42e oui là d'un
des grands pieds oui
[Applaudissements]
mais
manquerait quand même que le vendeur de
chaussures ressemble beaucoup aux
coiffeurs également fait tous les
métiers je rappelle qu on fait quoi
suivre et chaussures aller nos gens nous
disent on a deux banques à cinq
permanents tu te plaît ah oui oui
j'aimerais pour grand cabaret talent
show alors la boîte 6 et 6 mais si c'est
exact l'a3 l'a3 l'a3 la 3 voici le
premier à 10,1 donc c'est un chantier
d'entretien a perdu ses dents
oui vous avez tout à louvain alors on et
d'anti un dentiste en effet un truc de
fou un dentier un cd une personne
inforad entier un cd ou les vieux il
chante là comment s'appelle nrj 12
mais youval à ce méga tube no mad entier
un cd vous levez la main et c'est un des
chantiers un cd et christophe mali il
n'a pas fait son nouveau clip ou je sais
pas quoi
je suis moi tu crois tu sais que je
t'aime mélodies d'antan et la paix son
nouveau clip
mais oh